getting kicked out
hey and welcome to my office
spend a lot of time making this thing
look even that ceiling is covered oh the
audio here is so great and soundproof
isn't it or is it now that listen
there's no news to anyone that my videos
are loud alright and we spend a lot of
time on this room to make sure that I
can be as loud as I want and the
neighbors don't have to complain about
it sometimes however we're shooting the
other room let's go to the other room
how do I look sometimes we shoot in here
because we need a little extra space you
know what I mean a little bit of extra
movement and stuff so we're aware that
this room isn't sound isolated so we
usually just shoot here for an hour
Michael would you say that's correct
it's correct that is correct
we shoot here for an hour during the day
not a problem well guess what it is a
problem let's show the video
wait anger is coming so basically what
happened was we were shooting in HTC
vive video we were just done it was 4:00
p.m. on the day and then we get someone
knocking on the door basically we think
it's just some crazy guy who's just
pissed off maybe like a neighbor or
something like that he slammed the door
in Michaels face isn't that right that's
correct yeah he did call you a [ __ ]
huh
I think he called you a [ __ ] and the
landlord did this
the landlord himself we thought it was
just some random neighbor but then we
got a letter wait I gotta get the letter
then we get a letter see it gets my
tears on it even so say and it says
you're required to leave below a dress
after the 29th of June 2016 basically
the day after we have ever gotten a
noise complaint ever it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] alright we spend so much time
now we kind of move because of some
homophobe we're just pretty much it you
know if we ever got a complaint saying
hey you're being too loud can you try
and be more quiet we would not shoot in
that room anymore and then we get one
complaint and we get kicked out it's
it's [ __ ] [ __ ] plus if you're
gonna be a landlord in Brighton the gay
capital of UK maybe try not be a [ __ ]
prejudiced piece of [ __ ] how about that
I could buy this house I don't [ __ ]
need you alright it's hard to find
houses in Brighton I wouldn't want to
rent a place yeah it's a painting there
so today we're moving that's why we're
not having a proper video so I thought
I'd just update on the situation another
thing that happened is the day after we
get an actual noise complaint warning
how about that how about they start with
this [ __ ] and we were like hey Oh
we get a noise complaint after we get
kicked out that's really helpful it
doesn't matter it's brought to our
attention by some of your neighbors that
you or guests are causing disturbances
by creating excessive noise and they
call it antisocial behavior regarding
the porter report of noise late at night
6:30 p.m. you're asleep having a little
nap see are we disturbing your long lap
see guidelines on noise whereby noise of
any unacceptable level during the day
and between the evening hours of 11:00
p.m. to 7:00 a.m. you mean 24 hours
during the day and between 11:00 p.m.
and 7 a.m. [ __ ] you all right that's 24
hours we are never loud between 11:00
p.m. and 7:00 a.m. that's one thing we
always do we always shoot during the day
so we don't disturb the neighbors the
point is landlord [ __ ] you all right
luckily for us it's really easy to move
it's not a problem we have this
resources and we can just do it I
imagine for I don't know like another
normal person this being [ __ ] it
could throw them out on the streets you
know it's not that easy to find a place
in right all right let's pin that down
down mode let's check out the new place
see what we're excited about maybe it's
really cool said we got to spend all day
packing
hey welcome to the new office it's gonna
be amazing so much [ __ ] so many so much
shitty content it's gonna be made Jesus
Christ so much shitty content is going
to be made here we have this room we can
[ __ ] around look hopefully we can yell
as much as we want with the vibe here
and then we have my room oh don't damage
it I don't know all right near setup I
got a ton of these coming so I can not
put [ __ ] on the walls again
because the office the old office looks
like a [ __ ] war zone this is my setup
it's pretty cool because I that's all
you need to be pretty pine baby a desk
and a computer and a lot of sex appeal
oh boy oh [ __ ] oh boy it's hard being a
youtuber man Michael can you get me some
some drinks sorry this video was kind of
lame but it's gonna take a while to set
this thing properly up but we'll get
there eventually so thank you for being
patient while we're in this
transitioning prog process I'll see you
tomorrow with a new video and then you
setup maybe actually I don't know
probably not but as always
Oh